التنفس بالعام تنموذج بالسجون موجود بكل
سجون العالم
انه موجود بالطبيعه الاصليه له طبيعه
التنفس الحقيقي بمعنى انه سجين ساعات
طويله داخل غرفته داخل المهجر ايوه من حقه
ان ياخذوه ويكون في ساحه مخصصه للتنفس
يلعب رياضه بشم الهواء الطلق
يتمشى يعني اذا ما بده يلعب رياضه يعني
بمعنى هذا حق للسجين ايضا لكن في سجن مثل
سجن تدمر التنفس
يتحول الى عقوبه
بمعنى انه مثلا السجناء عندهم يوميه مثلا
ساعتين تنفس بالساحه اللي هن موجودين فيها
هالساعتين هدول بدهم يطلعوا على الشكل
التالي بده يكون مغمض عيونه
راسه بالارض
واي واحد بخالف التعليمات هاي قد تكلف
حياته
بده يمسك الشخص اللي قدامه طالع ما هو
مغمض عيونه ما عم بشوف بده يمسك الشخص
هذا من من ظهره ثيابه ايوه ويمشوا وطالما
هن ماشيين في هناك ضرب في هناك تعزيز في
هناك
في قتل بسبب المخالفه بهاي الحاله تحديدا
لموضوع اصناف التعذيب اللي مرينا عليه قبل
شوي انه المخالفه احيانا يتفنن السجان
مثلا بايقاع العقوبه على السجين المخالف
لنفرض انه شك انه هذا السجين فتحها عيونه
ربما
سجناء مساجين سجانين مو واحد واثنين يعني
موجودين ممكن يكون وجد من عشره 20 واحد
اللي عم بيراقبوا هدول السجناء اللي عم
بيدوروا داخل داخل ساعه التنفس شكوا بواحد
بيطالعوه طبعا شو بيعملوا فيه بعض
الالفاظ والمسبات والبهدلات والكذا هذا
مثلا بيعاقبوا بتفنن العقوبات انه انه
ساوي له مظله
شو يعني مظله بني مسجين على على ظهره على
الاسفلت طبعا الساحات كلها اسفل
بيجوا اربع سجانه كل واحد بيمسكه من طرف
واحد من ايد والتاني من ايد واحد من اجر
واحد من الاجر ويمرجحوه بمرجحوه وبيمرجحوه
وبيتركوا برتفع السجان السجين وهو على
ظهره
وبيهوي على الارض طبعا هاي العقوبه احيانا
كانت تؤدي للموت في نسبه اكبر من هيك بشوي
كانت تؤدي الى شلل بصير في كسر بالعمود
الفقري او
هذا ايوه فهذا احدى العقوبات اللي كانت
تمارس اثناء
التنفس في سجن تدمر
حتى انه كان في احيانا يصير في اجبار بعض
المعتقلين على شرب من مياه المجاري
اسمها التشريفه او الاستقبال اول دخوله
على السجن
طبعا كل السجناء الافاده على بده يشربنا
طبعا
التشريفه يعني في نسبه مئويه معينه مثلا
اجا دفعه فيها 200 سجين في نسبه مئويه
معينه من ال200 سجين بده يموت اثناء
التعذيب
بالاستقبال
اعذرني على السؤال ولكن انت ذكرت ذلك في
الروايه ماذا حصل معك شخصيا اجبرت على ذلك
اجبرت على المياه الاثنيها
مغسله مياه كذا طالع من
ماشي فوق الارض بس يعني انت بدك تتصور
مجمل المشهد وجو الرعب اللي عايش فيه وانت
ما بتعرف مصيرك وعم تشوف في ناس عم
بتساقطوا حواليك
وانت تخرج حي ام لا تخرج حي يعني كل
الحواجز بتكون موجوده بلحظه واحده طبعا
انك تشرب من المي الوسخه